fructífera reunión entre recepta y
perdón y bolo de mirt selenski en
Estambul el presidente ucraniano buscaba
asegurarse que Turquía apoyaría la
entrada de Ucrania en la otan según el
presidente Turco su objetivo se cumplió
no hay duda de que Ucrania merece ser
miembro de la otan me gustaría
aprovechar esta oportunidad para
reiterar lo que siempre he defendido
el mensaje de arduana es claro Turquía
no se opondrá la eventual adhesión de
Ucrania la alianza una garantía
importante para bola de mirza lensky en
un momento en que ankara lleva más de un
año bloqueando la candidatura de Suecia
también en el centro de las discusiones
las exportaciones de cereales desde hace
un año un acuerdo negociado bajo los
auspicios de Turquía permite Ucrania
exportar sus cereales a través del mar
Negro pero
Moscú no desea prorrogar el acuerdo más
allá de su fecha de expiración el 17 de
julio una que deja el fantasma de una
crisis alimentaria al aire
el mundo entero está interesado en el
buen funcionamiento del corredor
el mar Negro debe ser una zona de
seguridad y cooperación no una zona de
guerra
a pesar de las recientes declaraciones
de Moscú perdoan espera obtener una
prórroga del acuerdo el viernes el
dirigente Turco hizo oficial una visita
de Vladimir Putin el mes que viene es
decir después de que expire el acuerdo
al mantener lazos tanto con Moscú como
con kiev Turquía sigue desempeñando el
papel de mediador una actitud adoptada
por el país desde la invasión rusa a
Ucrania